appeared on Toppa poofy quiero para un
pedazo de change today show is the
Buddha action enough of a meeting
appolicious rajendra not so much more
adorable symbolism possession mouse
queen EAD symbolism todavia la solución
association a symbol is a toast or
symbolism na sahi lacrimation asado
it's been heartbreaking it's been
infuriating and also realizing that me
being here I'm a target I'm a black
person and anywhere I move in the globe
white supremacy is operating even living
in the u.s. I feel that and so being
here in Rio it's 10 times as much
you
I hope the impact will be international
outrage and that every story about the
Olympics run side by side with a story
about police homicide fondue is
monumental van ness sumatra piyush form
is Mihaly da zhi dao ma sector
disabilities are tambien I announcer
voice it's transient voltage tracker he
or mesmo tempo non voice I kill Brazil
Viper Room on donor